[Music]
all right hey check this out we talked
about two things today separately we're
going to talk about them in the same
[__] video today okay one we talked
about
snakes two we talked about cats now
we're going to talk about snakes and
cats because a 13t long python has been
surviving in a trailer park for five
months by eating cats by eating I heard
we're in Florida wow I saw this we're in
Oklahoma City South Oklahoma City Park I
was going to say I know they naturally
have pythons I don't think anyone does
really Everglades people dump snakes
yeah I think they dump them they have an
infestation because it's guys who are
like reptile dealers and they don't want
to get like the rare ones from like U
like overseas so they'll buy a bunch of
them so they just let dump them and then
they breed in there so they could always
go back in Everglades C them isn't that
crazy no I don't know if any of them are
native to America what do they are they
Amazonian or south or South Asian yeah
let's look this up pons are not from
North America right no I don't think so
what about anakan yeah what's the
difference between a Python and an
native to Africa Asia and Australia many
python species have found their way to
the United States thanks to their
popularity in the pet trade [__] rep
we reptile people wow Africa Asia and
but apparently reptiles are big [__]
money dude like really expensive I idea
the difference between a Python and
Anaconda anacondas are
huge I think Python's too while python
is a versatile programming language what
the [__] is
this dude I know in Florida there's so
many wild ones that they hire guys
straight just to kill them the Anaconda
is shorter thicker and heavier than the
python but they are both Ambush
predators that constrict their enemies
there are other subtle differ other
subtle differences anacondas are shorter
and fatter they started a movie with JLo
in Ice Cube yeah dude anacondas area
they're that movie is wild it sounds
like we're internet haters against Anon
it's not that big everyone says they're
so big not that big 20 ft is not even
that that large it's not even that
large there's buildings that are bigger
why are you guys freaking out about it
buildings that
are what is the biggest snake anac
Anaconda featuring JLo how come they
said they're shorter than a python
because people are [__] stupid
Python's not as cool a movie name but
pythons get pretty [__] big though
too and what about B constrictor B
constrictor they're both constrictors eh
is that a typ up python yeah I think
that's a branch or snake it's a it's a
brand just a it's a range of application
Tye ofage they fell off H nobody does
it's like Reebok I've seen a rattlesnake
in real life yeah scary at the desert no
I don't believe you I've seen tons a ton
I where dude Steve doesn't believe you
dude my school my school is like a
probably like a 20 acre campus literally
on the river in northern California they
got rattlesnakes every Springtime dude
we have like a school assembly and you
have a meeting like you see a snake you
do this every year [__] no bro dude my
uncle kids kill him no one bit of little
poor little girl and you'll just see
them like going around not crazy like
that but sometimes like some were like
in the playground one was in there you
go find like the you know management guy
and you know the the snake Handler yeah
we literally had one guy yeah we had one
guy at the school that knew what he was
[__] doing and you'd [__] with it so
I got Uncle with the ranch right and he
like he's got like three [__] anres
or whatever and there's a rattlesnake
like an acre away from us rattling and
my uncle being a badass has to get a
[__] sniper rifle and [__] shoots
a thing and it's like cool dude
everyone's all the way [__] there
yeah what you're a [__] Legend dude a
50 cow yeah set up like shoots it did
you guys eat I'm glad he didn't come to
my I'm glad he didn't come to my wedding
[__] little [__] spotter laying next
to him SP SC the sniper rifle is like
right here and then the snake's like
right there and he he's laying prone
he's adjusting he has a ghilly suit on
yeah he's a leite controller that's the
kind of white
time kak affiliated with unfortunately
you know apparently uh the cats like
they're faster than snakes and there's
videos of cats just [__] smacking
that snake snake's face and whatever pry
cool apparently not faster than python
that's probably a big one though like uh
ferrets and [__] right they fight
they'll be fighting snakes like that
like Mongoose
Mong cat racco and the snake the cat has
fast reflexes when they're like looking
at each other ready to but then they got
surprise
attacked going to be moments where a
cat's maybe just like a kitten or
something like that not really thinking
walking by why got make and then right
when they bite they [__] coil and
they're DZ both those shits are scary
cuz they're so quiet too too yeah I went
to a cobra Farm in Thailand and when I
was there uh they had a mongoose and
they had a massive fish tank and then
they just threw a [__] Mongoose or
the Cobra inside and immediately as soon
as the Cobra came in that Mongoose just
started grabbing its head and ripping it
like shredding it like it was paper wow
meanwhile there's a bunch of shirtless
Asians around holding up [__] dollar
bills hey he hey hey hey hey hey
[Laughter]
so it was like and the guy who B on the
Cobra was
like my
life bro it was so fast I was the snake
was get this [__] crazy ass out
of here and then the snake you know
charmer pulled that [__] out and
it was so quick the way that the [__]
immediately just came up to him and was
just like I was like what the [__] they
fight with their fingers that M just
climbs on top of the ropes up
believe in yourself glass shatters and
then a Ratt snake comes out and he has
to fight that guy does the snake ever
win snake comes out [__] knock speed
on his [__]
Spears does the snake ever win no yeah
no shot maybe if the [__] was tired if
you had to do like four fights that
night rounds yeah beat up might be tired
fatigue yeah that's usually why Mongoose
I'm really scared of snakes bro I do not
like them yeah really yeah I've like
touched them and [__] and like I said
there's Rattlers in front of us but
they're creepy I mean you ever read the
Bible you know them shits aren't good
you don't want like they [__] hold
those giant yellow ones and stuff if
y'all want like Hey we're all doing it
like all right d I'm going to do that
but I'm not going to pay $20 to put the
creepiest Critter on the planet on my
should it does feel good though it feels
nice and smooth I like it is the
creepiest Critter one of them it does
the kind of creep smooth titties I'd
rather put titties on my
head it's always either or that's puss
this guy straight I know you're straight
dude titties are
soft soft you know what else is soft
balls I'll put those on
my
wrist
okay yuck it's the end of the day dude
we're running out we're running empty
bro dud
yuck you think that happens at strip
clubs where everyone like yeah girls and
then the next one it's a man and it's
cuz they want to be inclusive and then
they're like oh man the why is Sam
that's why they have bouncers why is Sam
Smith get this guy [__] out of here
get the balls guy out of here he's back
again get the guy showing us balls here
out of here remember when we were at
well you weren't there we were at the
like not the Mulan Rouge but the crazy
girl Crazy Horse uh burlesque show in
Paris and then um they had a sideshow
act it was really funny and and um it
was uh M it was it was uh Robert Mr
frantic Mr Fantastic he's funny he does
the popping and he popped out of nowhere
and then yeah and then we thought oh
it's going to be a man stripper but then
it wasn't and it was a comedic relief
and I was like thank God thank God he
wasn't going to get [__] naked wait
so there's a bunch of strippers just
performing and then he was like comedic
relief as a performance act it's a
burlesk show intermission intermission
yeah but he's a he's a PO burlesk is a
little different though right that's
kind of classic it's very artistic got
me horny though still I've never been to
a strip club never been to a strip club
my life why it's worth it religious no
way no no no no yeah totally worth it
absolutely fun it's fun it makes you
horny yeah don't tell them I'm already
horny that's not hard to do it's
dangling a carrot hly no no no it's
actually I I got to be honest with you
it's really not like that for me anyway
like it's like sort of just sets a
different move like it's like oh cool
we're going to probably [__] later but
like it's like a we have different inspo
yep oh it's inspiration yeah y it's a
good way to put it inspiration is good
well cuz I I experien cheater though
like tell us like when you're first
strip club you talking to a mirror right
now look in look at the mirror not me
there's mirrors all
over I'm looking at you Stephen
experience cheater me I did cheat I did
cheat I own it I own it I own it credit
to me that's different check this out
accountability I exactly leadership
check this out I
cheated on chick that I told we were
boyfriend and girlfriend with but like I
didn't really mean it but I should have
but I didn't know she didn't give
[__] so I was like this can't work
but then I cheated on her with my ex so
that's couldn't be more above board than
that is it cheating because you went
right back to what you already [__]
yeah but be more above the best thing
about it is that for a couple months
because the chick that I was cheating
well the chick that I was with I guess
officially was hotter than my ex and so
I was was able to force my ex to like
dress like a [__] [__] and try to
[__] me for like months and she was like
doing that a lot it was awesome and she
to party to get more stuff to try to
[__] eek out more dick from me and I
was like damn this [__] is she's good
and I was like the new trick won't even
blow me yet so I was like at least my ex
has a huge leg up and that's why it's
fine that I did what I
did and I own it but unlike Anthony Lee
I own it responsibly even with the
record button on when they don't when
they don't give you [__] it almost
feels like they're not as hot yeah
that's what I'm saying she's like I have
jaw lock syndrome or whatever and I'm
like you're a
[__] [__]
[Music]
you
a